pleased to have here for the first time
is the hc of the detroit lions dan
campbell here on the rich housing show
how are you coach
i'm doing great rich i you know what i
want to start out just by saying this i
i commend you on all the work you've
done for saint jude thanks dan
i think it's impressive man i think it's
um
uh and i'll tell you the other thing
about it i love the fact you're getting
all these former players
that are still helping you out and
running and things but i've got a staff
full of these guys that think they can
still
run so uh you might just reach out and
see if we got anybody that can still run
i i've got a feeling you may beat half
of our staff by the way right now
well i can tell you this dan i think
it's great man
i'll tell you this uh dan um you can't
teach
uh what beats inside i wake up with it
every damn day you know what i mean i
look at it in the mirror every day
i will i will tell this to you and your
staff though is that if they think
they're fast
have them run a 40 on the field record
it and upload it
we'll take whatever whatever we can get
to con you know
garner as much attention to the fact
that we're raising money for st jude
you know i'd love to have you part of
the uh movement if you will it would be
great
you want to do that i got you well what
we may do if we do it we'll just do from
the waist up
just for the illusion of them running
maybe that'll
i like it the heart's there though
believe me no i like it you could add
like deandre swift's legs to the bottom
you know what i mean like that'll be
fine
you know no we'll see no one will notice
that'll be fine you can do that uh let's
so so uh i guess let's get into this uh
first up when did you
realize that you wanted a coach when did
that hit
was it the minute that you you you
stopped playing and
you know nine i mean when when you were
playing uh
being around people like sean payton and
parcells and
how how'd that one come about for you
yeah it's i would say this i uh as a
player
uh particularly i remember my rookie
year uh going into the office and coach
is coming out so i'm coming in at six in
the morning and they're coming out of
their offices with bed head
and uh i'm like man there's no way i'd
ever be a coach
you know i mean the hours they work the
time they put in i
um but i i think just something that
always sparked it for me
was my really it was my second year in
the nfl it was in the summer
and a buddy of ours they they had a uh
football camp a youth football camp in
pennsylvania and asked us to come out
and work it and
uh and i went out there and worked it
and essentially there was
i kind of told this story um but there
was a
you know hey go up there and watch the
tight ends they were in a 101 drill
and they were going against linebackers
and
and so it's one-on-one route running and
basically this linebacker this kid's
going against is just
i mean he's twice the length arm length
speed
agility like everything i mean the tight
end's got no business really being out
there and he can't even get off the line
so their coaches over there hyping it up
and they're all having a good time
because the kid can't even get off the
line of screaming so the quarterbacks
just like dirt in the ball because i
have nobody to throw to
and uh i watched a couple of reps and
then i just grabbed the kid and
i coached him up on a couple of things
just get off the line you know like
hey man you need to really sell this to
the outside make him think you're really
really running to the outside to the
sideline and then put your foot in the
ground
and club him you know you know so just
kind of gave him this whole
this whole deal on just a little
technique work and i'd be dang man he
did it to a t
and he crushed the kid and uh got open
caught his first ball but the look on
his face i'll never forget and i
that to me i think was always a bit of a
turning point like man that was
that felt great and just to see the kid
how excited
he was i felt like really opened up the
doors for me
somewhat and it was always in the back
of my head
um but then basically once you get to
the point to where
you know i'm in 2009 with the new
orleans saints i go down
with on injured reserve and i had a
pretty good idea my career was probably
done and now i'm staring at the rest of
my life and it's like well what do you
know and what do you love and it was
football and so i felt like
man you know just to get a little chance
at this is
is where i need to go with it and it's
certainly paid off
so you got a good parcel story give me
give me your best one that's safe for
we've got about a million parcels
give me a good one that's safe for work
i mean i can't get enough of them and
obviously you see you know he coasts the
cowboys you sign as a free agent there
after your stint with the giants where
you where you got a taste of the super
bowl
uh you got a good one where he or or
something
i got a great one i got a great i'll
tell you what here's one for you all
right so
this is one of the first times i'm we
had just gotten there and when he
he got there all right the cowboys he
just hired him in 03
and he gets sean payton and really
that's how i ended up in dallas was
because shawn vouched for me
and so i i go there and and so i'm new
you know it's his first year he's trying
to set the tone and uh
and so he wanted hard-nosed aggressive
guys competitive
all those things but you know fighting
you ended up it was a waste of time you
know it's a waste of reps to waste the
time
you know to fight it's one thing to
stand your ground but
so we get in there and there's a
basically a backup defensive tackle and
a backup defensive end
and we go rep and they get they get in a
fight and
they grab each other it goes we finally
get them broken up it probably takes 60
seconds for all this to go down
and uh and bill doesn't really say
anything and we go a rep again and they
get in it again the next rep
and we get it broken up you know takes
another minute or so
and so bill just stops practicing he
said okay
if this happens one more time he goes
we're all gonna circle up watch you guys
fight
and uh so we go a third time sure enough
these two get into it again
and bill we get them broken up bill
blows the whistle
he gets everybody in a circle and he
said you two get in here
he said take your helmets off both of
you and they take their helmets off and
he goes let's
go and they just stand there and both of
them are kind of cocked but they're
looking at each other they're looking at
bill they're looking around they're
looking at each other they look back
and neither one of them can throw a
punch they're like wait a minute this
just got real we don't have helmets on
they didn't do it and then he made him
run to the fence and so
anyway it was uh it was classic i mean
bill
there's about a million stories of of
what how he was and what what he was
about it's pretty good
real brief i'll tell you one uh that
i've told on this show before and at the
risk of repeating myself certainly for
the guys in this room
uh paul tagliabue told me this story
that he went when parcells was head
coach the jets they're standing on the
50-yard line and
uh practice is going down and there's
some goal line drills going down all the
way at the end of the field and parcells
is just
tearing people a new one based on what
he's seeing down in the goal line drills
and taglia
goes we're the same age he goes i i can
hardly see five
feet in front of me without my glasses
bill how can you see 50 yards down the
field
he takes out a list of names out of his
pocket and he goes i can't see a damn
thing i just
made a list of 10 guys i was gonna tear
a new one today i'm on number three
stick around i got seven more to go
that is 100 coach that is marcel's man
i'll tell you what you knew when it was
your day
you're getting it it didn't matter what
you did man it was coming
i assume you had your day one of those
days i'm sure you had uh
something like that yeah i had my day
they'd come around everybody was gonna
get it he
look he it didn't matter even if you you
know you're playing pretty good you're
not a guy who's gonna make mistakes
you're pretty smart you're kind of
everything he's looking for you're going
to get your day
because he wants to know how you react
to it i mean that he was
he was so much into the psychological
part of the game you know
and uh i tell you what man he would
nobody could push buttons like that man
could
dan campbell here on the rich eisen show
and now you've got your shot being a
head coach
um and one of the first moves you make
if not the first move you make is to
is to make a move at quarterback that
was beyond um
you know i i guess generational for your
team because of
who was traded away and uh the draft
choices that come
in with another quarterback that's a
first overall
drafted guy what what are you seeing
jared goff that says
in your mind that this is the guy from
my program coming out of the gate
yeah well look i think there's a number
of things but i just always know this
you know we've had when i was with the
saints we had a lot of battles with the
rams over a three-year period
and uh really a four-year period and i
tell you what man that guy
um even when if we got the upper hand on
him which was
really didn't happen a ton we always had
some pretty good battles
um that guy was and we had a pretty good
defense but he was unshakable
and uh he always man high scoring games
and
he is making throws getting hit in the
chin and getting back up on his feet and
he just was steady and solid and i
remember
thinking man this kid's pretty tough and
uh and then when you see the success
he's had
you know when he gets hot he's he's as
good as anybody
when he gets on a streak but i think the
kid is tough his nails i think he's
durable
and he's won a lot of games man i mean
you know i i get all the well you know
his quarterback rating this and that and
look man there's ebbs and flows that
happen with a lot of guys in this league
import
and particularly the quarterback
position but they're
this guy's got enough he's got enough in
there man
to uh to certainly help us win games and
and he's experienced he's been through
it and uh
and so we're pretty fired up to have the
guy so what does the offense look like
what can you tell fans of the honolulu
blue of what a an offense head coached
by dan campbell is going to look like
with goff at the controls
what does it look like yeah i think
we're going to be pretty multiple
is what i would say i mean we're you
know are we going to want to run the
ball yeah we are but that doesn't mean
that you know we're going to try to run
it 50 times a game or something but we
want to be as balanced as possible
we are going to run multiple schemes you
know we're not going to just live in one
one world or another in the run game and
we're going to be multiple in the past
game we'll have enough
you know three-step drops we'd like to
do a lot of run action pass
and uh certainly uh there's enough in
there to where we think maybe we can run
some empty packages but
aside from that we want to be as much uh
you know match up based as possible
i mean to me look everybody for the most
part most teams run just about
everything now there's you know there
used to be the west coast and then there
was the
zampeezy you know the the number system
and the speed
outs and the five seven step drop down
field throwing get
and everything is so so meshed now
together
that it's not so much about what we're
going to run but who's running it and
so we're going to find our match-ups we
want to get the ball in the hands of our
best play makers
and you know we have a couple ideas who
we think some of those guys can be but
until we get them in the building
you know and get a real good look at
them we won't know that but we'll find
all that out
but i i'm much more into putting people
in the best position
to have success and and you know we'll
run some of the plays that most teams
run but
but our deal is instead of uh well this
is where the ball goes by coverage let's
put the guy
in that position knowing that coverage
is going to dictate
where it's going and and we know it's
going to go to that guy you know
so i would say in a nutshell that's what
it's going to look like
offensively dan campbell head coach of
the detroit lions here on the rich eisen
show i'm
you know i'm always appreciative of
talking to a head coach in the league
certainly six days before draft and i
know you're not going to lay out
um anything about your your your plans
for next thursday night that said
uh you're in a fascinating position
seventh overall
an opportunity to have a ton of talented
players playmakers out wide
um as well as a possible possibility of
a quarterback
dropping to you and the phone ringing
potentially off the hook for somebody
who
wants it how are you gaming this out
right now
six days before the draft seventh
overall
well i would say this first of all i i
i wouldn't normally do this because i
like you rich i'm gonna do it all right
i will promise you this we will not pick
at number seven a kicker a punter or a
long snapper
that's a promise all right
it's going to be crazy but breaking news
that's where we're at i appreciate the
scoop
dan i got to be honest with you man well
i know i
i appreciate it um but
i would say this we brad holmes has done
a phenomenal job
i mean he has hit the ground running and
he and his staff
and all these scouts and even the
coaches all of us this has been a
collaborative effort and
and we we have deep dived and done our
what we call the club sandwiches man
you're stacking players at each position
now you like that player now let's stack
them
uh across the board you know where does
this where does this tackle relate to
this receiver and to this tight end
and to this quarterback and and and
we're just trying to come up with
with what we think is the best player at
the position where we're picking
and uh they will fit us best you know
and
you know there again we're all about
we're no different anybody else we want
to win
now but we also we're we're looking out
too man we want to see where we're at a
year from now
two years from now and and you know it's
we want to make sure that we're picking
the best guy that we feel like is going
to fit us you know we don't want to go
into this thing and
and feel like we have to draft by need
necessarily doesn't mean if there's two
equal players or whatever but
it's been a great process and i'm
telling you man i can't speak high
enough for brad holmes
and the work that he's put into this and
uh so we're we feel pretty good right
now still a lot of work to go though but
before thursday so how do you stack it
where somebody say
uh very talented white out from alabama
name either one of the two
or our guest that was right before you
uh who said he had a great zoom chat
with you who's six three 246 runs a four
three nine forty but plays on the other
side of the ball micah parsons
what is your philosophy there coach give
me that one
seventh overall let's just game it out
yeah what do you think
yeah that's look that's it's a good
question i would just say this man i
feel like when you're picking at number
seven
whoever that player is needs to check
every box in my opinion and
and i think brad feels the same way i
mean top to bottom you're talking
everything
from the intangibles to the the
you know what is he a prototype uh how
does he look how does he run what's his
production
like everything across the board and you
know i
um let me tell you something i know all
three of those players are
i believe worthy uh in that range i
could tell you that man they are all
very very
very good football players and they're
all different certainly so
um anyway i i uh i tell you what it it's
it's pretty fun
is what it is and we're having a blast
doing it right now but
you know i would be happy with any of
those guys
and um you know before i let you go here
um
did did you hear from anybody in your
your family loved ones
uh after your introductory press
conference and some of the
uh quentin tarantino type language that
you use to describe your philosophy
coach did you know i've heard from a few
members of my family and friends
that i certainly may have but look they
know who i
am they know what just kind of what it's
just me
and um i i kind of a passionate guy
and i speak what's on my mind and how i
feel and sometimes i get going and
but that's that's just me and uh so they
were all good
but uh but no that that's it is what it
is you know what i mean
did you hear from your dentist saying
hey you got i heard you got your teeth
kicked in is everything all right did
you hear from
like you're an oral surgeon or anything
like that
he dialed me up immediately he was asked
if i needed some dentures it's not
saying i mean my gosh
i just don't know if that was part of it
i was just trying to set the tone rich
that's all
you certainly set a tone there's no
question about all that man and
i i look forward to seeing how it all
plays out in a town that you know
having played there is just absolutely
thirsty
for some w's and championships and
things of that nature
beyond thirsty on that front oh and let
me let me say this real quick rich
let me say one more thing quickly is in
regards to that
i just for all your listeners i do know
because i've gotten this a little bit
i've heard this feedback
i believe me i know 100 that biting a
kneecap is a 15-yard penalty
i think it's more than that you might
get a fedex letter in your locker
coach you know i mean i'll be honest
with you
there might be there might be a little
bit something on a tuesday or through
friday that you might hear from
new york city but uh okay i'm glad at
least that's clear
and there will be no first round long
snapper kickers or punters for the lions
and
i've enjoyed this conversation let's do
it again i appreciate what you had to
say also at the top
about saint jude and please if your
staff thinks they're they're fast have
them run
put it out there as you know the eye in
the sky film does not lie i'd love to
see it and uh
hashtag it run richrun and help raise
some money i'd love it
all right sounds good rich i appreciate
it man for the call you got it enjoy
your first draft as the hc of the
detroit lions dan campbell right here
on this edition of the rich eisen show
biting an ecap is definitely
unsportsmanlike conduct
he's correct not reviewable oh i don't
think so well it's reviewable by the
league office to see if there's
something more that's coming
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here